I love seeing this with an audience I'm
curious how many how many times you've
seen it with all users I haven't seen it
with an audience I'm seeing it with an
audience for the first time tomorrow
night and then there's a London premiere
and a New York premiere and then I'll
never watch it again but yes I do think
that this particular film lends itself
to a theatrical experience a because
it's an incredibly made film and you
know the sound the sound in itself is
really spectacular which is not
something that I would usually comment
on but it is really really outstanding
and contributes to the whole kind of
piece in a really profound way but also
it is a scary movie and there's a kind
of nervous energy that builds up amongst
people when you're watching it together
and I imagine there's a sense of kind of
safety in numbers it was really
interesting to just see kind of grown
men I'm not scared
but you're so right about the sound it
was like that's something I normally
wouldn't even notice and it's not it's
not distracting it really like
contributes and fades the story but it's
it's very specific and kind of
fascinating right it was it was like
there's certain moments where I'm like
oh yeah going on here I was really under
Preda below what was it like on set
because I know Alex Wolff is like a very
method actor were you kind of all like
that uh I wouldn't call him it that he
likes to torture himself Easter Saturday
yes of course he does um he's young
every mean everyone works differently
and the story was quite demanding but
there was a general set I think
sometimes when you work on something so
dark then a natural kind of sense of
levity presents itself just to balance
out the whole experience
I'll Gabriel Byrne is delicious to work
with I cannot believe I had the
opportunity to work with him I've been a
fan for so many years I remember I told
him recently when I first came to
America I was doing press from the earls
wedding and I was kind of taken around
to different parties at Oscar time and
someone had said to me you want to come
over meet the donor and I was like
okay and I walked over and she was
talking to Gabriel and I was so excited
to meet him and I would never have
envisioned having the opportunity to
work with him in the future so I loved
work with him
and out my god she's the most open
present beacon of light it's so exciting
working with her there's so much room
for spontaneity and both the kids were
very very good and worked in completely
different ways I think Ari just created
it's really exciting to work with
someone who has such a strong really
strong and original vision and he just
knew before I'm sure five years before
we even started he knew every shot
cutting point nuance everything that he
wanted and he just you know he guided us
through yeah I mean it was it was
Millie's personal I think was always
personal as well like what was it about
the script that you knew it was
something special and unique that you it
was just really obvious and evident
there's nothing like it which is what
you yearn for where as an actor um and
it was an opportunity to absolutely go
for it and not in a sensationalized roar
overdramatized way it's a very very
honest look at grief and you could have
watched this family navigating through
something so painful and so profound and
once you've invested in them emotionally
you're not expecting that the story's
gonna go away over there and I think
that's so clever of Ari to have done
that and it was sent to me as a genre P
I know you're not interested but just
you know check this out and I was really
going where's this where's the scary
stuff they mentioned because to me it
just felt like this kind of poetic deep
beautiful story yeah it's like you
really don't know where it's gonna go
and I feel like a lot of horror movies
are very predictable you kind of they
kind of go to this climax and then these
big moments but it was really like up
and down and kind of all over the place
yeah and I would I would I've only seen
it I haven't watched it with an audience
and what I watched it in little Hotel
Manchester when I was working on
something else and from the very first
shot I mean I love watching back
everybody's work and seeing the
combination of everybody's efforts but I
really could feel from the very first
shot it is so confident in itself it has
its own rhythm it's not pandering to
anything else and for a first-time to
direct director to have just that that
knowledge and and that vision is he
really is the real deal I'm so excited
for Ari and to watch what he does and
he's gonna have a real career he's the
real deal
I'm hearing it everywhere
oh my god no I got home last night
somebody like shoved like slam together
I can't watch scary movies are really
can't really yeah it'll be good that
you're with an audience though well I
mean I've got a totally different
experience I was there obviously making
it but yeah I can't even I don't know I
mean I like this one because it's not
just scary right there's so much more to
it but I yeah even as a kid I go to
summer parties and people who put on
like Nightmare on Elm Street and stuff
like that and I was never able to
stomach it um I loved watching this is a
really really great performance from you
um it wasn't like the physicality onset
of you know because you've had to get a
scream a lot in this movie what are kind
of the there are a lot of extreme
emotions and see how this one and I
really loved that she's not you know
there's a lot about her that's quite
contrary and to be able to you know tap
into someone's
grief and rage and desperation and
resentment and it was just so much it
was so complex and it was incredibly
exhausting
but it was really satisfying in a kind
of perverse way I just think it's such
it's it's something that affects
everyone you know great grief it's part
of the human condition and I just I
would hate to not just give it a certain
amount of truth so I did yeah as a do
job as an actor to make it feel as
honest as possible and in order to do
that I think you know if you're watching
something if I were and it's too
technical it takes me out of the story
so I don't know any other way other than
to kind of put myself in that position
and really feel it and that ends up
being I don't advise that it is
exhausting I mean you do really go
through that journey with your character
being like is she losing her mind is
this stuff really I love that ambiguity
yeah it becomes more and more kind of
maniacal and you really can't tell
whether she's finding the truth or
losing it maybe it's bad maybe a little
bit of both yeah yeah but I love this
movie I had a hard time writing
questions for cuz I'm like I don't want
to give it away to any I know it's
difficult to talk about you did well
[Music]